he endured five hunger strikes in the
last 10 years of his life but the body
of 45 year old
couldn't take it anymore he was found
unconscious in his cell in a rumbly
prison in Israel on Tuesday before he
was announced dead
Adnan started refusing food when he was
arrested on the 5th of February he was
later charged with offenses including
provocation of violence and belonging to
Islamic Jihad an armed group Israel
considers a terrorist organization
we do not want any response from those
who had failed to put an end to the
injustices done to other to the Israeli
occupation forces before the Palestinian
Authority or resistance factions I say
remember the faces of all my children as
they are raised to appreciate nothing
more than pride and dignity
in 2012 became a household name in
Palestine the baker had refused food in
protest against his detention without
charges his 67-day hunger strike ended
with Israel agreeing to release him then
again in 2015 he was freed after a
55-day hunger strike I see the happiness
among Palestinians flowing in the
Palestinian pain and the hope for the
freedom of all prisoners God willing
his success inspired dozens of
Palestinian prisoners to protest against
such detentions by going on hunger
strikes the majority of those individual
actions led to Israel giving in to the
prisoners demands
in 2020 maheras was released after 103
days of hunger strike
they want to break him and Palestinians
through breaking him because he is a
symbol of resistance and steadfastness
he is a freedom fighter they want to
show that they have the upper hand in
control
Palestinian officials and Islamic Jihad
leaders have condemned his death saying
it was an assassination by Israel
people across the West Bank have closed
their shops and businesses in protest
against his death hunger strikes are one
of the few non-violent tools left to
Palestinians as they battle against
Israel's unfair legal system set within
a context of long-term occupation and a
regime of apartheid for many here Adnan
has become a symbol of resistance
against the Israeli occupation they say
what happened to him should bring
attention to the plights of thousands of
Palestinians suffering in Israeli jails
many of whom without a charge
the occupied West Bank
Rockets have been fired from Gaza
towards Israel since adnan's death Hamas
Islamic Jihad and other Palestinian
factions in Gaza have held a solidarity
rally to honor him shops and businesses
in Gaza have also been closed following
calls for a general strike
let's get more now from Gaza and join
yumna al-side so first of all tell us a
little bit more about this barrage of
rockets that were fired towards Israel
yes so the Palestinian factions here
through their giant chamber uh The Joint
chamber uh said or unclaimed
responsibility for firing barrages of
rockets towards the southern Israeli
towns uh they said that this comes in
response to the crime committed by the
occupation of killing
and they also said that this is just an
initial response and warrant the Israeli
occupation of of any foolish retaliation
now we can hear above us in the skies of
Gaza actually
F-16 Israeli war jets a flying um in the
skies of Gaza as I speak to you right
now and also we uh we there is a very
cautious call in this in the in these
hours waiting for the Israeli response
to the launching of the Rockets from the
Gaza Strip towards those Israeli towns
okay um many thanks for the moment let's
go over now to West Jerusalem where we
can speak to Muhammad Jam so Muhammad
we've been talking about what the
response is going to be we're now
hearing uh F-16 Israeli war jets flying
over the Skies of Gaza any clear
indication as to what the Israelis are
going to do
well Laura here's where we're at at this
hour when it comes to any type of
Israeli response we know that prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu is meeting
with top security officials to try to
formulate a response we've also heard on
Twitter from the country's defense
minister johav galanti tweeted earlier I
completed several operational situation
assessments following the rocket fire
from the Gaza Strip the security
establishment will act with the
determination and force against anyone
who tries to harm the citizens of Israel
now we heard earlier from the Israeli
army they confirmed that at least 22
Rockets were fired from Gaza toward
Israel today according to Israel's Army
16 of those Rockets landed in
unpopulated areas four were intercepted
by the Iron Dome defense system the
Israeli Army also went on to say that
there was at least one rocket that
landed in sterot in southern Israel as a
result of that there was shrapnel that
injured at least three people one of
those people who is a foreign laborer
was uh is in moderate to critical
condition and everybody who was injured
as a result of all of this uh was taken
to a hospital in the southern city of
Ashkelon now key right now to
understanding what's going to happen
next is what exactly is Israel going to
do if they decide to respond certainly
it would be a surprise if they do not
respond in in some way typically if
Israel responds to Rocket fire they do
so in the overnight hours that would
mean either later tonight or very early
tomorrow morning now if Israel were to
respond by let's say firing if they were
to to launched air strikes onto let's
say empty fields in Gaza that would
indicate that they don't want to
escalate the situation that it's just a
message being sent if on the other hand
Israel were to hit let's say Islamic
Jihad or Hamas Targets in Gaza that
might indicate that they actually would
want to escalate the situation further
and that this could be more drawn out
going forward as of now it's more of a
tenuous calm we should also mention that
Israel's Army has informed the residents
instead that they no longer need to take
shelter in fortified areas near Gaza
that indicates that it's a lot less
sense than it was earlier in the day but
at this point very much a holding
pattern and we'll just have to wait and
see what happens next Lord we will okay
Muhammad for the moment thanks very much